dans une fête patronale le jeu est de
compter les personnalités présentes
et à ce jeu-là sainte-marie gagne
toujours serge letchimy jean philippe
miller alfred marie-jeanne d'ordinaire
leur présence font des étincelles
mais aujourd'hui l'esprit de marie plein
sur eux je ne suis pas venu non plus
tout faire d'escarmouches avec quiconque
parce qu'elles savent bien loin de vous
la fête sainte marie par ouaga tomber
pour moi c'est l'essentiel en politique
d'abord à la fois de l'humilité total
roulant célébrer l'assomption de la
vierge marie nous devons à la fois cédé
mais l'humilité et le respect je ne
viens pas ici parce qu'il ya les
échéances électorales bien quoi vous
serviez mieux que quiconque
l'énorme investissement collectivités
pas de passe d'armes politique alors
intéressons nous à deux des
personnalités civiles mises à l'honneur
lionel l'orne et paul beaulieu le
premier est un jeune samaritain
installés dans l'hexagone
il a créé une entreprise d'import de
pièces électriques il a été fait citoyen
d'honneur
j'avais une envie de créer quelque chose
ça faisait beaucoup d'années que je fais
si c'est à la création d'entreprise est
en fait c'est que on est jeune on a les
capacités
on pense toujours que c'est les autres
mais nous on a les capacités de le faire
quant à paul beaulieu c'est le directeur
administratif et financier de
saint-james d'origine haïtienne il a dû
batailler pour être acceptée en france
mais a été repéré par le groupe saint
james
quand on débat que dans un pays étranger
et qu'on est haïtien c'est la croix et
la bannière
maintenant une fois qu'on sait
livrés à la réalité de l'environnement
on se bat et souvent les gens s'étonnent
que on arrive toujours à faire quelque
chose des samaritains mis en avant et un
maire qui ne pense pas encore à la ctm
mais bien plutôt aux prochaines
municipales
quelles sont ces français quelles sont
ses décisions d'abord géré la vie
continuait à réinventer ce prix du bois
donner un mot c'était la dernière fête
patronale avant les municipales sans
doute le dernier rassemblement avec
toute la classe politique